ribeye this is the new Philip it's a
chef's dream it's got this wonderful
casing of fat separating the chain and
the ribeye so as it cooks
this fat just imparts more more flavor
it just melts in your mouth
delicious wrap nice and tight set that
in the fridge and we're gonna come to
cut my portions they're exactly the same
size and more importantly I haven't
waited anything fridge half jokes look
they're nice and firm but it's really
nice sort of celeriac stroke nutty
flavor to them this time here perfect
you cut off the stalks remove leaves you
know when to stop when you start seeing
that really nice light colored leaves
inside take your knife and then just
peel down through the stalk
now that's your artichoke prepped lemon
that stops them from oxidizing basically
going Brown and just cut them in half
look at that that's the beautiful
celebration of spring
water lemons salt white wine vinegar
pepper olive oil
what let the knife do the work and look
at that that is beautiful hot pan
cooking the ribeye you've got to be
quick olive oil salt pepper get all that
seasoning soaking up now look at that
beautiful garlic crush Rosemarie into
the pan that's the noise you want to
hear that sizzling you ever got that get
it back out of the pan so that color
there absolutely phenomenal butter this
is where it starts to take the state to
a different level this butter is really
bringing out the texture and a flavor of
the meat out onto a plate and just leave
it to rest griddle olive oil take out
your ass shows salt and pepper
is the good okay perfect turn them over
artichokes off
call
and that is a dream come true ribeye our
beef griddled artichokes done if you
have fruit that's not perfectly ripe the
tip is to put a banana in a paper bag
then add your unripe fruit put it in a
dark place